melissa is in Fresno California I'm
Melissa how are you I'm gonna find in
yourself better than I deserve what's up
the question I have is combined at me
and my husband bringing about $5,000 a
month
Tycho Tycho Brahe yes take home pay
about $5,000 a month between the two of
us now our bills only amount up to about
25 $2,600 a month that's including our
mortgage our payment everything your
mortgage in your car pay your mortgage
in your car payment or how much our
mortgage is about 850 our car payment
with insurance is about another 450
regular light electricity they care
maybe about another six seven hundred
I'm a kid you got briefed that's low in
Fresno okay yes so our problem is we're
trying to figure out where to spend
don't exactly I mean where to see we
don't exactly know how we're still
finding ourselves check to check okay
well the problem is you're getting on
the wrong side of this the money's gone
and then you're trying to look back and
see where it went
yes instead you need to tell it where to
go before it leaves and so that's called
a budget and we're going to sit down and
write it out we just did some of it we
said okay $5,000 if that's accurate is
at the top of the page and you need to
actually look at your check stubs and
make sure that's accurate no yeah that's
that's definitely accurate okay that
guys at the top of the page for a given
month we take out 850 for house we take
out your ridiculous insane car payment
of 450 we take out your actual day care
which with three kids you're saying that
and electricity is only 700 that sounds
like it's half of what it should be you
know that's about what it is I mean we
get a really good deal on daycare what
do you pay for daycare for daycare for
children I pay about $400 a month the
other one is old enough to be in school
ready there's no after-school care yes
after school but she just goes with
family for about an hour but it's not
charged no so 400 there and so you're
saying 300 covers your lights and water
yes okay what are you spending on food
no killer with food yeah who knows okay
and you continue to go down the list and
i'll send you some budget forms okay to
help you remember what needs to be on
the list to give you just kind of your
jog your memory or where the money might
be going i mean you probably have
insurance coming out of some kind
somewhere you have car insurance
yeah well car insurance that's combined
it in with about before 54 that car
payment for the other car swin Jocelyne
a gasoline is about another maybe two
you see this is what we've got to do
until the 5,000 is gone and the trick is
you and your husband look at that and
say okay these are the things we're
going to pay with this money this month
and we're not going to use money for
anything else and so before the month
begins all the money is spent on paper
on purpose every dollar has an
assignment has a mission and you don't
let any dollars go out anywhere you or
your husband except to that mission
because you're telling me you think
you've got room in this budget and you
can't find where the money is going I
think you've got room in this budget I
agree yeah
yeah I think you're probably spending
more on food than you realize number one
and some of the other stuff sounds low
still but I mean if you actually know
what the bill is you know what the bill
is that's fine
and so let me just tell you the first
month you do this it'll be wrong and so
you'll get halfway through the month or
week into it and you'll have to do some
adjustments but at no point can the
budget can the budget formula be any
different than income minus outgo equals
exactly zero every dollar has to have an
assignment and so if you get a weekend
and you realize we got to spend little
bit more on food then you got to take it
out of something else
because you can't spend more than you
have you're not in Congress absolutely
okay yeah I think this organization and
Walmart and Target and raising kids is
more expensive than you realize and and
eating out are probably eating up the
balance of this I don't think you're
being extremely wasteful but I think
you've got a good thousand to 1,500
bucks in here you're going to find a
better purpose for as you do this you
will feel like you've gotten a raise
when you start making this money behave
yeah because that would be our next
question I mean aside from okay going
through and budgeting I mean we only
have maybe about a thousand dollars
saved up just you know in case in
emergency right well we got it we got to
get on a program of what to do with the
money once we find some and so finding
some by being on a plan is your first
goal and then what to do with the money
we call the baby steps and that's your
income and that's the first goal is to
have a thousand dollars say the second
goal start paying off your debts which
would include the decision to either pay
this car off or sell it what do you owe
total on this car what's left on the car
is about forty five hundred what's the
car worth the cars worth about thirteen
you completely got screwed on the
interest rate then what do you pay an
eighteen percent around there it's close
to rare
you bought a car you absolutely should
not have bought you got completely
messed over with your bad credit and you
completely impulse and that kind of
decision is where your money is going so
get that stinking thing paid off
that'd be one of your first goals as
soon as we start finding some money is
get that thousand dollars in there good
and solid and then let's get after the
getting them paid off as soon as
possible from there so hold on what I'm
going to do is have Kelly send you a
copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover which is a book that millions
of people have used to do just what
you're trying to do
number one get in control on our monthly
budget and number two what to do with
the money once we're in control the
budget forms are in the back of that
book
and if you want to do a quick easy
online budget there's a ghazal budget
light it's called it's a free tool on
our website at Dave Ramsey comm for a
beginner budget in a day helps you do
this stuff automatically so jump in
there and learn about that as well but
in the meantime hold on and Kelly will
pick up and we'll get you a copy of the
book the Total Money Makeover one of the
things I've heard over the 25 years of
teaching this material and I've heard it
the most often is Dave when I got on a
budget a written plan I told my money
what to do instead of wondering where it
went I felt like I got a raise and
that's that I've heard that over and
over and over again America and there's
no exception to that it's written game
plan on paper on purpose this is the
Dave Ramsey show
you